- Uh, hey guys.
It's probably dark in here.
I'm learning lighting.
Actually, it's behind that's bad, right?
That's the good lighting.
Look at that, is that good?
- [Babin] Yeah, that's good.
- I'm a genius now.
Watch this, Babin.
Is this good, is this good?
- [Babin] That's great.
- Amazing.
In Seattle, in some tunnel right now,
doing some backseat answers.
Hectic day, a bunch of Amazon stuff.
Hopefully we'll get some
content, but Bab and I,
it's been really spotty these two days.
But that's just the reality of actually
being the CEO of a 200-million
dollar holding company.
I work, I'm not an influencer.
By the way, influencer is work, but
I run a 900 person company.
I try to remind people.
Because they raz me for like,
'hey why don't you like two mix it up?'
I'm like fucking working 15 hours a day.
Can't go on a fucking kite or snowboard.
I also don't have those skills.
Alright, Shawn has a question.
- [Babin] Shawn: If you
had 10 to 20 thousand
in your bank account today,
what business would you open?
- 10 to 20 million?
- [Babbitt] Thousand.
- Oh, thousand.
(Gary laughing)
That was a funny slip-up, thousand.
I would start a, ironically,
a retail flip business.
Because I think 10 to 20
to 150 thousand in one year
is very realistic if you
learn the art of the flip.
Buying stuff at wholesale, close-out,
go to Toys-R-Us right now, clean them out,
buy their stuff, put it on
Amazon Marketplace, put on Ebay.
The grind of the flip is remarkable.
You know, church sales,
town-wide sales, thrift stores,
Alibaba, wholesalers, liquidation sales,
buying bulk, buying bulk on Ebay,
breaking it down and reselling it on Ebay.
Craigslist Free.
If you have 100 dollars,
and you go to Craigslist,
and go to the free
section, you can probably
get to 10,000 year one
if you actually fucking
worked, you motherfuckers.
Like, it's work.
Everyone's looking for
the fucking secret sauce.
There's no fucking lazy
fucking juice out there.
Lazy juice is not real.
It's a pipe dream.
No passive income, you gotta work.
- [Babbitt] Alright, we got
a question from Garrett.
It's a nerdy question.
- Okay, let's go nerdy.
- [Babbitt] Just opened
up my third yoga studio
with my girlfriend and
we want to leverage voice
and wanted some advice
on what direction to take
our first audio classes,
podcasting, Alexa skills,
things like that.
- I would go podcast.
I would start a yoga show.
And I would make it about
yoga, but also the journey
of building out three studios
in a short period of time.
Also, the dynamics of running a business
when you're boyfriend and girlfriend.
Your truths.
The answer to all your
questions are your truths.
The most interesting
and compelling content
you can make is your truth.
Babin's most interesting
content is not the photos
that he takes or the videos he makes,
which are remarkable,
and he's very talented,
it's the journey of how he got here.
Like, why did he take the job?
How did he see it?
Does he really, how does he
handle the DRock razzing.
Does he like it?
Does he hate it?
What's he thinking about?
What's the long-term?
When did he realize he should bet on me?
What's going on?
How does it affect his personal life
in his early twenties being this busy?
Who has he learned from besides me?
What, how, who wins at Vayner?
Who loses at Vayner?
What's scatter really about?
Does he really act like that in real life?
You know, what have you learned?
Why is traveling fun?
What do you do when you can't film with...
Your most interesting
content is your truth.
I think we hit this the other day.
My content's boring.
I'm a business man, I'm in
meetings 15 hours a day.
I'm in meetings 15 hours a day.
Yes, I'm entertaining,
charismatic, increasingly handsome,
I get it, but none of that
stuff is driving value.
What's driving value is my ability to
communicate what my day's about.
And if you can figure that
out, you're off to the races.
I mean, you know, a
successful show would be about
somebody who is being lazy.
Here's my truth, I'm entitled, I suck.
I just want to play video games.
I think it's going to
come to me naturally.
Finding out what happens to Sally
after she realizes that
after a year of vlogging,
is the most interesting part.
Your truth is undefeated.
- [Babin] Who were your favorite
rappers back in the day?
- Notorious B.I.G., The Fat Boys,
I was a huge Bone Thugs-N-Harmony fan.
Too Short, I love Too Short.
KRS-One.
That's what stands out.
- [Babin] One more nerdy one?
- Yeah.
- [Babin] Gary, you
mentioned in a recent podcast
that Pokemon Go is like the
Friendster of today's AR world.
- Meaning it was the first
kind of thing that broke out? Okay.
- [Babin] What do you think Facebook
would look like in an AR environment?
- That's a great thing.
That's a great, great question.
If we're going gaming,
if we're going gaming,
the Facebook is just a
game that is being played
by people for seven to 10 years,
just a game that never quit, you know?
But I think AR has a lot
of other functionality
besides gaming, and so, a mapping,
a Google Map or an Apple Maps,
a start-up, a Waze like character
could pop up around maps
that were incentivized.
Imagine you had a map app that was AR,
that was super effective,
got you to where you wanted,
but every time you poked
into the real world,
there were things going
on that were good, right?
So we're here at T-Mobile's
campus right now.
Imagine if we're using
the map to get to where
we're going to this meeting,
but it also popped, like
in that bush right there,
or here, just put it
against that wall, right?
Imagine in an AR environment, that wall,
it also has like 25 dollars
off your subscription
or the competitor is
putting up, like, you know,
a Verizon, switch now and free for a year,
the gamification of our
world through a utility
I think is very interesting,
whether that's maps
or other things, and so what happens
when you're walking through an airport,
utility because you're
trying to get to your gate,
but also you're being sold
or gamified along the way,
I think there's clearly
huge potential for AR,
but I think AR really hits it crescendo
when we go to contact
lenses and not phones.
When we're working through a voice,
kind of like a seamless
computing environment,
with ears, ear pieces and contacts,
you can really get into some crazy shit.
If you're switching literally
through your voice activation
at first, between AR, VR and reality,
that mixed reality world,
it's really interesting.
(jazzy music)